almost 80,000 people have signed a
petition demanding italy drop criminal
proceedings against german boat captain
pierre clamp 35-year old skipper of a
rescue ships accused of abetting illegal
immigration after she personally
assisted in the rescue of more than one
thousand migrants they were at risk of
drowning and unsafe Dinky's as they
attempted to cross the Mediterranean to
reach Europe Martis maria for national
reports this is the case of pierre Klemp
a german boat captain and hero to some
criminal to others she was at the helm
of the EU vent about in August 2017 when
it entered the port of lumpy dooms are
located on an island between Malta and
the coast of Tunisia the rescue vessel
was detained and Pia's lawyer now says
she may face up to 20 years in prison
and horrendous fines but no matter what
pious stance is unwavering we have
witnessed what women and children have
to face if they are denied safe travel
by ignoring the submarine boats of
European warships and expelling Libyan
militias for brutal people who shelter
refugees from unsuitable overcrowded
scraps and pick them up sometimes too
late
Italian investigators have accused her
crew of colluding with smugglers with
photos leaked to the media a legend the
boats returned to libras coast on
purpose to be used again by smugglers
today it hasn't been set yet for with
Klemp has dubbed her show trial and many
agree tens of thousands of people are
back in her in a petition calling for
Italy to drop the charges
this however falls under Matteo Sal
Venus crackdown they Tallinn Interior
Minister and Deputy Prime Minister is
known for his open and strong anti
migrant views to stop rescue ships that
are carrying migrants from docking on
Italian shores and allowing refugees to
disembark it's what has been after since
his appointment last year and he has
supporters too it's not as though the
Italians acted without probable cause
there is much truthful reporting that
every year of Investigation preceded the
arrests including videos witness
statements Deutsche Welle depicting
their
as rescuing people from drowning is BS
propaganda rescue them and take them to
Germany it is quite convenient to rescue
people and leave them in Italy Greece
etc we have enough migrants we do not
want anymore she enables the trafficking
of people that's illegal she's
responsible for the so-called refugee
crisis there is a clear split within the
you over how to tackle the migrant
crisis and while they seat undecided on
whether to assist or hinder the flow of
migrants into Europe captain Pia Clem
could be losing her battle at sea and on
tour
you